good evening the struggle against kovid
is the single biggest crisis the world
has faced
in my lifetime in less than a year
this disease has killed almost a million
people and caused havoc
to economies everywhere here in the uk
we mourn every person we have lost and
we grieve
with their families and yet i'm more
certain than ever that this is a
struggle that humanity will win and
we in this country will win and to
achieve
what we must i want to talk to you
directly tonight
about the choices that we face none of
them easy
and why we must take action now
i know that we can succeed because we
have succeeded before
when the sickness took hold in this
country in march
we pulled together in a spirit of
national sacrifice and
community we followed the guidance to
the letter we stayed at home
protected the nhs and saved thousands
of lives and for months with those
disciplines of social distancing
we've kept that virus at bay
but we have to acknowledge that this is
a great and
freedom-loving country and while the
vast majority
have complied with the rules there have
been too many breaches
too many opportunities for our invisible
enemy
to slip through undetected the virus has
started to spread again
in an exponential way infections are up
hospital emissions are climbing we can
see what's happening in
france and spain and we know
alas that this virus is no less fatal
than it was in the spring
and the vast majority of our people are
no less
susceptible and the iron laws of
geometrical progression
are shouting at us from the graphs that
we risk
many more deaths many more families
losing loved ones before their time
and i know that faced with that risk the
british people
will want their government to continue
to fight to protect them you and that's
what we're doing
night and day and yet the single
greatest weapon we bring to this fight
is the common sense of the people
themselves
the joint resolve of this country to
work together
to suppress kovid now
so today i set out a package of tougher
measures in england
early closing for pubs bars table
service
only closing businesses that are not
kobe secure
expanding the use of face coverings new
fines
for those that fail to comply once again
asking office workers to work from home
if they can while enforcing the rule of
six
indoors and outdoors a tougher package
of national measures combined with the
potential
for tougher local restrictions for areas
already in lockdown i know that this
approach
robust but proportionate already carries
the support of all the main parties
in parliament after discussion with
colleagues in the devolved
administrations
i believe this broad approach is shared
across the whole
uk and to those who say
we don't need this stuff and we should
leave people
to take their own risks i say these
risks are not our own
the tragic reality of having coveted
is that your mild cough can be someone
else's
death knell and as for the suggestion
that we should simply lock up the
elderly
and the vulnerable with all the
suffering that would entail i must tell
you
that this is just not realistic because
if you
let the virus rip through the rest of
the population
it would inevitably find its way through
to the elderly
as well and in much greater numbers
that's why we need to suppress the virus
now and as for that minority
who may continue to flout the rules we
will enforce those rules
with tougher penalties and fines of up
to ten thousand pounds
we will put more police out on the
streets and use the army
to backfill if necessary and of course
i'm deeply spiritually reluctant to make
any of these impositions or infringe
anyone's freedom
but unless we take action the risk is
that we will have to go for tougher
measures later
when the deaths have already mounted and
we have a
huge caseload of infection such as we
had in the spring
if we let this virus get out of control
now it would mean that our nhs
had no space once again to deal with
cancer patients and
millions of other non-covered medical
needs
and if we were forced into a new
national lockdown that would threaten
not just jobs and livelihoods but
the loving human contact on which we all
depend it would mean renewed loneliness
and confinement for the elderly and
vulnerable
and ultimately it would threaten once
again the education
of our children we must
do all we can to avoid going down that
road
again but if people don't follow the
rules we've set out
then we must reserve the right to go
further
we must take action now because the
stitch in time saves nine
and this way we can keep people in work
we can keep our shops and our schools
open
and we can keep our country moving
forward while we work
together to suppress the virus
that is our strategy and if we can
follow this package together
then i know we can succeed because
in so many ways we're better prepared
than before we have the
ppe we have the bets we have the
nightingales we have new medicines
pioneered in this country that can help
save lives and though our doctors and
our medical advisors are rightly worried
about the data now and the risks over
winter they are unanimous that things
will be
far better by the spring when we have
not only the hope of a vaccine but one
day soon
and i must stress that we're not there
yet
of mass testing so efficient that people
will be able
to be tested in minutes so they can do
more
of the things they love that's the hope
that's the dream
it's hard but it's attainable and we're
working as hard as we can
to get there but until we do
we must rely on our willingness to
look out for each other to protect each
other
never in our history as our collective
destiny
and our collective health depended so
completely
on our individual behavior
if we follow these simple rules together
we will get through
this winter together there are
unquestionably
difficult months to come and the fight
against kovid is by no means over
and i have no doubt however that there
are great days
ahead but now is the time
for us all to summon the the discipline
and the resolve and the spirit of
togetherness that will carry us through